tis the season for Oh black mirror and
the bizarre phrase the black mirror
Christmas special white Christmas man
okay
lot to deal with here reminder in case
you're new around these parts there will
be spoilers why it's in the title so my
perspective on this is going to be a
little bit odd because I'll remind folks
that I started watching black mirror
with season four and I watched the
entirety of season four and then have
now gone back so there's things that I
am going to reference that I know fully
well are actually calling back to this
but for me because of my watch order it
feels like it's calling back the other
way around
so I'm try and keep it straight in terms
of what actually came out first but if I
screw it up there's that so structurally
it's not dissimilar to black Museum
actually the framing device is a lot
less blatant than black Museum was black
Museum was very much here walk through
this player walk through the space and
I'll tell you stories of these various
pieces of technology it was a it was
very blatantly a framing device where is
this it starts in his opens like huh
what's going on here and then it flashes
back for the first of what I end up
being three segments and each of these
segments he gave me different feelings
of unease and I also knew that in the
framing so I knew something was wrong I
knew something was off and weird and
some we you know some something was
gonna drop him regards to all that it
took me a little while to figure out
what it was but I
I was expecting from the beginning but
there's gonna be something up with this
so let's start taking these one at a
time and then sort of overview the whole
thing so we start with the whole
basically hook up coaching thing which
well I was gonna say the the ending
didn't lose me but in some ways was was
almost an over reach but let me get
there first the whole thing of watching
this got one this guy this group of guys
coach this awkward dude through trying
to hook up with a girl made me deeply
uncomfortable which I think it's
supposed to because I mean look the
whole the whole hookup culture the whole
idea of pickup artists is it's always
been kind of skeevy and it's it's
feeling much more so now than ever used
to and there's something about it
especially in this case where I think
even if someone's like you know it's
just guys being guys you watch it in the
context of this show and you still start
to get that feeling of oh this is this
is a bit much you know as you have this
guy's looking up also social media
information like these people's names
and things about them and you know it it
makes you realise that the actual sort
of culture of pickup artists tree for
lack of a better term is you would
absolutely do that if they have the
ability so you know that that and that
tapped into you know the feeling of
discomfort unease just tap into that
really well and that sunken and in it
helps that the guy who's being coached
is fairly likable he's just seems like
an awkward guy who's trying to get
help so that that keeps it from being
what it could have been which would have
been just watching this ski be sleazy
guy work his way through the situation
which would have been kind of
insufferable but it's not in this case
now the twist I it's fine it works it it
kind of came out of left field a little
bit
I felt I mean I'm not completely there
are hints to it to where it's going that
are laid out before it actually gets
there but it I don't know the whole
thing just felt a little a little too
while to use the same comparison I use
when I talk about black Museum a little
to just from the Crypt sort of you know
ironic fate thing and then it I don't
have probably the ironic fate so they
they can be a lot of fun black mirror
fun it's not the word most people would
use but I don't know it just seemed it
didn't seem quite like what I would come
to expect from bike mirror again though
I'm now sort of realizing that this is
kind of a side thing that the show does
every now and then going for a bit more
of the outright yeah ironic fate thing
usually would be shorter was like I said
the the first time I noticed something
like this was black Museum so I think
it's something that they kind of keep
them reserved for their stories that are
shorter that they're just trying to wrap
up in a shorter timeframe and then they
don't have the time for the character
beasts and to let the things breathe the
way that they normally do but that that
was good put me in a state of unease and
so then next up we get what is in many
ways the pre could it's a combination of
two things or more accurately there's a
two concepts in here that would later
get split and sort of isolated as their
own thing later on in season four so
we've got this whole thing the whole
cookie concept which in terms of the
ideas that later get branched off of the
whole idea of a copy of somebody as
somebody's consciousness their their
memory
their understanding that is just code
but feels like it's the real person that
obviously I explored later on in two O's
and I suppose I have to warn about
spoilers for season four as well to a
certain extent sorry
so that could exude that gets explored
later on in USS Callister and then the
whole sort of being trapped inside this
being consciousness trapped inside of
this thing and you know the being on the
inside looking out I got revisited in
one of the black museum segments later
on but this isn't just a culmination of
those two ideas visiting because it adds
the extra thing of this kind of almost
being the next generation of like Alexa
her you know or ciri or you know any
sort of AI assistant you know what's the
next level from a learning a
theoretically you learn you know there's
the things you can talk to this what we
have now next step from that would be a
learning piece of software that gets to
know you better the more it interacts
with you but you know what's what's even
better than that software that already
knows you completely wet completely well
down to the letter because it
effectively is you and that's actually
kind of a cool idea in a lot of ways but
the the way in which that has to be done
the way in which you bring the the AI
construct in line is awful is really
terrible and terrifying like the the
concept of literally being able to do
nothing for weeks or months or years
that yeah that's that's really kind of
terrifying to sit down and think about
for any extended period of time
and this also introduces the whole block
element but we're gonna we're gonna get
back to that a little bit later oh yeah
that didn't really get introduced there
it got introduced in the previous
segment I'm
maybe that's miss mixed up I'm a little
bit tired and I'm emotionally drained so
you'll have to bear with me here so then
finally we get after hearing basically
two segments narrated by Jon Hamm we now
get the last story narrated by this
other guy and we get the story of him
and this woman that he had a very close
relationship with but didn't work out
and she and they got in a fight and she
blocked him and this sort of
extrapolation of the of the block button
on basically any social media app
whether it's Instagram whether it's
Facebook whether it's anything else you
literally block someone from your life
and I feel like in some ways arcangel
revisited that to a certain extent like
just because you can't see it and don't
have to deal with it
doesn't mean it's not there so the the
whole idea I that went that whole
concept went some interesting places
like I found it interesting that or at
least some of my takeaways from it cuz I
I do find that with black mirrors
sometimes what I read into a situation
is not what other people read into it
which is always fun to find out but sort
of my takeaways from that is the ease
with which we can just block somebody on
social media if we were able to do that
in life and have it be that easy that's
again may potentially kind of awful
because is it a good thing to be able to
cut a real person out of your real life
not just your digital existence but your
real life that easily and you know I
can't say it's it's wrong to be able to
do that if the technology exists because
I can think of plenty situations where
that would be a very good thing to do
but aside from that certainly the way
this presented presents it like I really
think about the consequences of that and
the severity of being cut off and I
I'm not gonna lie I really felt for this
guy
when that daughter turned her on I knew
that there was gonna be something about
that they were they were holding off on
on showing her face Oh before I get
there though this last segment is shot
gorgeously all the stuff that goes on in
the snow it's it it's almost looks black
and white but then we get these pops of
really vibrant color so all that is is
really fantastic and you've got this guy
and you know the this daughter that he's
watching from a distance or trying to
cuz she he's blocked from being able to
see her just as much as with her mother
but when her mother dies in an accident
the block gets lifted automatically and
when he sees her face and sees instantly
that it's not his daughter I really did
feel for the guy and not because of oh
my god she cheated on him because the
show did the correct thing in terms of
addressing the impact on him because for
him as far as he was concerned his
daughter just died of course the reality
is he didn't even have a daughter but he
thought that she was pregnant with his
kid
he observed as best as he was able to
with the block this kid grow up over she
looked about for four years or so and
living with that like I'm a father
I'm not part of her life but I'm a
father and finding out that that was not
true for him feels like his daughter
just died
was just killed and I even though I knew
I knew was gonna go bad and I had I had
a very paranoid feeling about how bad it
was gonna get which would turned out to
be correct
but I I did feel for him when he's in
that kitchen just going
where's my daughter and the pain of that
but then of course and I started to get
an inclination of not the specifics of
what was going on but where things were
gonna end up basically as soon as he got
into that kitchen when he followed the
kid inside and got in that kitchen I
recognized it boom I mean they've got
the zeroing in on the clock and he
reiterates that in case anybody missed
it but as soon as he walked into his I'm
like oh god that's where he and Jon Hamm
are and I didn't I didn't make the leap
in my head that it was a simulation or
anything like that but I am watching
that going he's there they mentioned at
the start of this passage of a
significant amount of time the
grandfather is not there the young girl
does not appear to be there this is
gonna go really really really badly and
it's awful it is just awful the the guy
leaving and this little girl up in a
room alone with no one to take care of
her and trying to leave and go get help
she leaves a present for her grandfather
who's Leaney hits the wall dead and she
goes out into the storm and oh yeah that
that was um I was hard for me that was
really hard which shouldn't come as a
shock for anyone has been following me
talking about black Americas I brought
up repeatedly how endangered children
are tough for me and especially if it's
more more than endangered yeah
so and I think it was it was a very
smart idea to not have this kid ever
speak
at any point because I think giving the
kid too much personality honestly would
have killed it because it's really hard
to get a convincing performance out of a
out of a kid that young out of an act or
that young so by not having her speak at
all it I still felt like I got this kid
and got that one just that one shot of
her laying on the floor of her bedroom
and probably been there for a couple of
days by that point oh man and so then
then we get out you know our big twist
it's it's kind of a confessional thing
and Jon Hamm is awful I mean we knew
that already from from what we saw but
he just steps out and basically the
world is blocked for him you know he can
go out and he can walk and he can be in
the world but he can't interact with
anybody and you know that's sort of
that's existentially scary after a much
more visceral gut punch that that third
segment and again it's the combination
of I feel the father's pain for feeling
like he lost a daughter Betty was
convinced he had and then what actually
happens the kid Oh God
yeah I I'm exhausted I'm drained I am
emotionally beat and I think I just need
to crawl in bed and hope I don't have
really really depressing your screwed-up
dreams after watching this particular
one it's good it's really good it's very
affecting Jon Hamm is good and he's
charming as he always is and that's good
for somebody this skeezy because
otherwise it you know you just kind of
like why am I dealing with this guy so
it helps that he's charming and he's
inherently likable
so he was good the other guy was good
whole thing yeah that that worked really
well and it's interesting seeing how
some of these things are concepts or
forward moved technology that gets
reused again and in either newer ways or
ways with a more specific focus than
this episode had so the thing that's it
there were probably other things that
that I wanted to say or meant to say but
like I said I I'm just beat at this
point and I debated doing this in the
morning but I I feel like I needed to
talk about this while the emotions were
still raw because oh yeah just just damn
black mirror why can't I quit you so
black mirror white Christmas have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts were drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all that stuff you
that you can do so for me on patreon buy
a t-shirt follow me on Twitter listen to
my podcast links for all that and more
is down in the description so until next
time and hopefully a good night's sleep
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]